were you surprised that
he lost to dake in the trials to kyle
dick
oh kyle's so so he's so good right i
mean i think i think his performance in
the olympics was uh
was his last name which was shocking too
i mean we never seen it happen to kyle
dake you know he's been a guy who's
competing with jordan burroughs forever
and obviously he was on the losing side
for a while and now he's on the winning
side um
but i think a lot of people thought it
was a coin flip and i think actually
kyle digg made it feel like
it's not a coin flip it feel it now to
me it feels like kyle dick is going to
win that match significantly more times
than he isn't is what it feels like yeah
i forgot which trials it was
was it four years ago
where
kyle dake threw him
like he
he no no you saw inklings of like yeah
oh wow there might be a eventually a
changing of the guard yeah so 13 kyle
came out and he had the one throw
but then he lost one of the matches
decisively
um and then he was hurting 14
and in 16 kyle dick actually went to 86
kilograms so in actually in 16
at the trials we had um so jay kerber
was number one seed he was former as guy
russell i was a former world silver
medalist so you had uh david taylor who
had not made a team yet who is now a
world champion olympic champion you had
kyle dake in the bracket who was a
two-time world champion now and you had
jaden cox in the bracket who had not
made any teams yet but is now what a
four-time world medals two-time world
champion so and then obviously jaden
came out on top of that won his first
olympic medal big bronze medal um so
kyle didn't wrestle jordan in 16 and
jorda and kyle's contention
the whole time
and they argued about this so i actually
did a little bit of backstabbing well it
was not it's not acceptable both of
i didn't tell any of them okay okay so
jordan got mad so we thought we talked
about this fake mastering chrono right
we yeah we had to make we had to make up
something to talk about yeah there's
obviously no matches
so we talked about this fake match and
do you stand behind that statement by
the way listen here's what i said kyle
kyle takes four times state champion yes
i said you got to pick a you got to pick
a winner i said kyle dick wins 2-1 on a
minute and six ride time which i mean is
literally we're talking yeah as close as
it gets as close as it gets for kyle
jake who's a four-time ncaa champion i'm
sorry
sorry we're talking over jordan
burroughs over jordan borrows interfocus
in the folk style match the hypothetical
college you're not hypothetical now or
in college in college both of them at
their peaks at 165 pounds so completely
hypothetical and so jordan called in he
was all pissed
at me for picking kyle dick he wants to
come on the next day and argue his point
yeah so i said
f that that's that's dumb we need to
pick a winner way to do something
hypothetical so that i called caldegra i
said kyle jordan's gonna come on and
argue his case in the morning if he's
gonna do that why don't you come in and
argue your case
so no one else knew kyle was coming
around the box yeah so they both show up
and they went at it but one of the
contentions kyle had for years and
there's still this rule if you win a
world level medal
the following year
you sit out until the very end of the
american trials
and they do they do a best two or three
so every time previously that kyle had
wrestled jordan he had to come through a
tournament on saturday yeah okay
probably three matches and then on
sunday he would wrestle jordan invest
two out of three right so his contention
was i'm only wrestling jordan at a
disadvantage because i have to compete
on saturday and then competing on which
it's a fair argument it really is but
i also see usa wrestling's point is like
if someone wins a world medal we are
going to reward them because we want
that person on the team again so it's
crazy though that you're like kyle jake
had to wrestle because he's not
wrestling bums in that box yeah and and
then
yeah i don't know i don't know how
wrestlers do it because
yeah
you have to go to war like three matches
and then face jordan borrows yeah
especially a few of those years with you
know daycad uh
the name andrew howell but those were
really competitive matches david taylor
had really competitive match with him
isaiah martinez even got in there
dearinger so he had some really
competitive matches before he ever got
to uh jordan burroughs so i never
answered your initial question was uh
how did i feel so
the jordan burroughs match i was not in
wrestling shape at all meaning
wrestling's heavily dependent especially
neutral positions heavily dependent on
timing and other things i was wrestling
very very minimally because i was i
started fighting again so like my [ __ ]
athletic shape was great but it was
mainly for fighting i wasn't wrestling
so um i think they were actually trying
to do
burroughs dig at the beat the streets
it's a big it's the biggest fundraiser
in wrestling every single year in new
york in new york city they usually raise
like a million dollars they started all
these programs in new york city to get
which that i really want to do with the
money now because they probably can't
have the kids wrestling because new
york's crazy anyway i think new york
figures out a way what to do with the
money hence michael mouse complaining
that they're corrupt and all that go but
it goes to the beat the streets
organization who then starts the clubs
in new york so i don't know what to do
with mine anyway so i was called like i
don't know two two weeks before the vet
and said hey you know someone saw us to
wrestle jordan burroughs it fell out
would you wrestle him
i said yeah sure why not you know and
it's like
melissa i i trained with him for four
days the year before i had a pretty good
idea how the match was going to go it
wasn't going to go so well for me but
it's like okay you're missing a main
event i can bring because of where i'm
at right now in my life i can bring a
lot of attention to wrestling i can help
you guys raise a bunch of money for beat
the streets
my goal is i think i thought i could get
one takedown or turn on him was kind of
my goal for the match i didn't get there
uh it went kind of hard he went hard
yeah that [ __ ] didn't give me a point
yeah the that
i said this is [ __ ] jordan i told
him in the match like this is [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] going too hard right now
yeah i'm not a wrestler i'm not a
wrestler i'm a fighter i'm coming in
here so yeah so i i had a really good
idea i mean we wrestled together i think
in it he'll probably get mad because i
think in the live go we did like the 12
or 15 minutes i think i actually scored
a takedown in that i believe maybe or
maybe it was a turn he'll probably say
no i didn't but whatever um yeah so i i
knew what was going to happen i i knew
what the outcome was going to be i knew
i could probably hope i could stay
competitive and maybe you know lose like
10-2 or something like
you